à l'arrière du centre social on peut
voir l'étendue des dégâts
une salle entière est véritablement
carbonisé dans le quartier ce matin des
habitants ne cachent pas leur
indignation
c'est inadmissible c'est pour tout le
monde
faux pas ils brûlent et fonds pai abîmé
justice pour jamal une inscription sur
les murs du trait d'union pour justifier
la 110 samedi dernier un jeune du
quartier âgé de 39 ans perd la vie au
cours d'une rixe avec un autre individu
le drame créé une vive émotion à
l'émotion succèdent ensuite
l'incompréhension le juge d'instruction
a décidé de remettre en liberté sous
contrôle judiciaire l'auteur des coups
intolérable pour les jeunes que nous
avons rencontrés
même s'ils disent ne pas cautionner les
incendies de la veille nous on en colère
on en colère on en colère parce que
voilà la personne a été libéré à la même
parfait 24 heures de garde à vue
c'est pas c'est pas normal c'est pas
normal c'est anormal c'est anormal
ici il ya des jeunes ils sont rentrés en
prison et un mandat de dépôt pour une
conduite sans permis
hier après midi déjà près de 100
personnes en colère avaient manifesté
devant le commissariat une délégation
s'est présenté hier après midi au
commissariat pour être reçus et avoir
des explications
nous l'avons reçu et nous avons pu
échanger téléphonique - louis se
procurerait public qui a expliqué donc
la procédure et comment allait se
dérouler et donc ils sont repartis en
lançant d'ailleurs un appel au calme
un appel au calme lancés notamment par
la famille de la victime mais qui n'aura
pas été entendus
la maire de montceau les mines souhaite
que les auteurs des troubles soit
identifiés et sanctionnés fermement
elle tente ici de dialoguer avec les
jeunes qui au delà de la sphère se
sentent délaissés
ça n'est pas acceptable ce n'est pas
acceptable il n'y a pas de monde il y à
une société mons et liège
il y a une vie à montceau et tout le
monde doit doit vivre dans la bonne
entente
le commissariat de montceau les mines a
reçu des renforts pour maintenir la
sécurité sur le territoire des prochains
jours
une enquête est ouverte pour
dégradations dangereuse par un salut